I want you to think about a person you met
in the last month that was so memorable, that
you remember them till today.
Can you think about that person?
I'll give you a second.
Think about that one person that you remember
till today, that you met for the very first
time.
You got it?
Here's a question.
What made that person so memorable for you
to remember till today.
What made it memorable?
See, no matter what you do, as an entrepreneur,
as a business person, you're going to meet
a lot of different people.
A lot of different people.
And you want the person, the customer, the
person, investor, the person you're trying
to recruit as an executive, whoever it is,
you want them to remember you.
And the more they can remember you, they store
you here [in their mind].
Okay?
They store you here.
So there's two different ways to be memorable.
One of the ones is that people are naturally
memorable.
They have certain gifts that makes them naturally
The other one is people learn how to become
memorable.
Today I'm going to tell you 11 different things
that you do to become memorable in other people's
lives.
So with that being said, let's start off over
here.
#1: Your unique style.
Everybody has a unique style.
Let me give you an idea about unique style.
Paul, why don't we tell them about Joe Jordan.
Joe Jordan is a well-known insurance guy in
the industry.
He used to work at MetLife.
Very well-known.
If you look at Joe Jordan's picture - let's
put his picture up.
He always walks around with this bow tie,
and he's always got this black and white shoes.
It doesn't matter where you see this guy.
You're going to recognize that.
He's got this beard that's part of him being
memorable, right?
Another part of your unique style could be,
certain people have certain tattoos that makes
them memorable.
It could be ink.
It could be your style of how you wear your
clothes.
It could be your height.
It could be your body, your muscles.
It could be your eyes.
It could be your voice.
It could be.
. . there's got to be something unique about
you that when people see you, your style,
that's you.
That makes you memorable.
By the way, everybody watching this, you have
something.
Everybody watching this.
Some people say, "I'm not tall, so I can't
be memorable."
Believe me.
A lot of people remember Sylvester Stallone.
A lot of people remember Tom Cruise and a
lot of people remember these guys, and they're
all 5' 6", 5' 7".
They're not 6' 8" or anything like that.
You got to play to what makes you memorable.
#2: I put here ha, ha ha because it's humor.
People remember funny people.
If you ask so many girls, if I ask 100 girls
and I asked them, Hey, why did you marry your
husband?
And they will typically tell you, half of
them may say, "I just love his sense of humor.
He made me laugh."
He made me laugh.
Humor works, not just with girls, not just
with guys, humor works with human beings,
period.
If you can have humor, if you can do it in
a way where people catch it, they see it,
they feel good, they laugh, they walk away,
they remember you.
And they say.
. . this is how the conversation goes when
they walk away if they're with another person.
"That guy was pretty funny."
Did you hear what he said about that one story?
That was hilarious!"
They remember you.
You're memorable officially when they leave
you.
#3: Follow up.
Let me tell you what I mean by follow up to
be memorable.
You meet somebody for the first time.
Like I met a guy for the first time and he
wanted to do very good in real estate.
He started in real estate, and he said, "I'm
going to very good in real estate.
I'm going to do this in real estate and I'm
working with my family and I'm doing this."
Okay, no problem.
I left.
He had started part-time.
He was still a bartender at this restaurant.
He had just passed his real estate license
that week.
I went, bought a book, How to Master the Art
of Selling.
Next time I came, I said, "Hey, you told me
last time you're in real estate."
He said, "Yes."
I said, "This is a guy who sold 365 homes
in a year.
Read this book.
It will help you out in sales."
Every single time I go there, I don't pay
for my drinks any more.
I don't pay for food.
He pays for my stuff.
Why?
Because it's follow up.
You're memorable.
He's going to remember this guy I told him
one time about a certain thing I was doing
in real estate, and he came back and brought
me value.
He's memorable.
Memorable.
So then he's going to give me - there's a
relationship there, where I'm going to help
him, he's going to help me out.
#4: Next, eye contact.
It's a simple thing but people like eye contact.
They remember eye contact, because it shows
you're not afraid to look into somebody else's
eyes.
#5: Next, questions.
You know, a lot of times you'll be in a conversation,
and we were having a conversation, a debate
going on.
And during this debate, there was eight of
us, we were all CEOs.
Everybody's doing 10, 15 million plus per
year.
A couple of the guys were in the half a billion
range, and they were doing pretty good for
themselves.
And we were talking, going back and forth,
and I kept asking questions that was getting
to a certain answer.
And one of the guys says, "I've never met
anybody that asks questions, unique questions
like the way you ask questions."
I said, "Well, I'm trying to get to the bottom
line faster."
You're asking questions that require nine
questions, and I'm already on number seven.
Because I already got the first six.
Sometimes unique questions you ask, that person
walks away and says, "Wow.
How did he think about asking that question
from me?
I never thought about that.
I like that guy.
I like how he thinks.
Who is that guy?
Can you tell me about that guy?"
You're memorable.
#6: Next, point of view.
Think about T.V.
personalities.
Think about Barkley.
Everybody in the media right now's talking
Barkley because of the comments he made about
LeBron.
It doesn't matter whether LeBron likes it
or not.
It doesn't matter if you agree with it or
not.
It's a different point of view.
That's all it is.
And that's memorable.
Now there's good memorable and there's bad
memorable.
This is a neutral one.
Some like it.
Some don't like it.
Anybody that works on Fox, CNN, MSNBC politics,
they're journalists, they have to give their
point of view that's different than everybody
else.
If your point of view is vanilla, then there's
a problem.
Like the other day I was getting into a debate
with somebody about Mexico and should we put
a wall up, should we not put a wall up, and
I said, "Here's a crazy idea."
The guy said, "What?"
I said, "How about we do the following.
This solves 90% of the problems.
We still have some problems, but we solve
90% of them."
He said, "What is it?"
I said, "Why don't we ask Mexico to be the
51st state of America?
Borders are gone.
He said, "What do you mean?"
I said, "We don't need borders if Mexico is
the 51st state of America.
Then the president of Mexico becomes a governor
and we allow Mexico to have similar guidelines
that we have with Texas as a state in the
U.S. so Texas can always, if they wanted to
- you know, it's technical, they can be their
own country.
How about Mexico gets the same right?
So now we create jobs in Mexico, we're creating
jobs in America.
Business owners in America would have no problem
creating jobs in Mexico.
It doesn't matter.
There is no border.
No one's jumping a wall or doing anything
like that.
Mexico is not a part of America and now Mexico
may support America to clear the borders around.
If other people from other states or countries
in the south want to come into Mexico.
And somebody could say, You could also be
the 52nd state of America.
Now some of you watching this may say, "That
is the dumbest idea I've ever heard."
But I guarantee you 80% of you guys are thinking
about it.
That's a different point of view.
It's a different way of looking at it, is
point of view.
Have different points of view.
#7: Next, pay attention to details.
I think a lot of times people don't pay attention
to details.
It's just oh, here we go and they did something,
no one's paying attention.
Pay attention.
People leave so many signs when you talk to
them.
There are so many different signs when you
talk to them.
When they answer the phone, what name is that.
It's a sister, it's a girlfriend, it's a husband,
it's a wife, it's kid, it's someone's birthday.
Just pay attention to details.
There's so many different signs when you're
talking to somebody.
And one person that's very good at paying
attention to details, they're very memorable.
#8: Next, your story is your signature to
the world.
Period.
Your story.
How you are, your personality, is a signature
to the world.
How you are if you have charismatic or charm
or certain style or. . . that's your signature
to the world.
Only one person has this and it's you.
That's your signature.
Your own story, how you grew up, where you
came from, what happened to you, who were
you in high school, what struggles did you
go through, what victories?
What things interest you?
Are you interested in philosophy, sports,
baseball, basketball, art work, baseball cards?
You know, flowers, wine.
You know, you may like a certain type of whiskey.
What is it?
That's interesting.
People want to know.
It makes it memorable, if you can figure out
your signature, and you tell that in snippets.
You ever talk to somebody sometimes I got
some people I mentor and I say, You know,
you do so well in the first three minutes.
The moment you go after the first three minutes,
you're trying to brag so much.
It's too much.
Just bring it back.
You go 35 minutes.
They're on overload.
They're not impressed any more.
You seem desperate.
Just a little bit.
One line.
Two lines.
Three lines.
Come back.
Same with girls on dates.
Don't go way, way too long impressing somebody
else.
They're seeing a lack of security.
You're trying to make up for some area you're
insecure in.
Your signature's plenty enough.
Find a couple of different interesting things
about yourself and say that.
People will remember that.
#9: Notes.
Back in the day, it was index cards.
Today you can literally take your phone out,
you can literally take your phone out and
go to the notes section of your phone.
If you take your phone out and you go to the
notes section of your phone, guess what?
You can put notes of anybody you just met.
Anybody you just met can put here.
Okay?
So the notes will be, people I met.
Then you put John Doe.
Details.
. . Bop bop bop bop bop.
Great.
And then what happens eventually is okay,
I met this person in Chicago.
I met this person in Nashville.
I met this person over here.
Eventually, hopefully, your brain, your memory
gets better.
And you automatically are better at remembering
names or remembering information and remembering
data.
But let's just say that still doesn't happen.
It doesn't matter.
You have all the data over here.
Makes sense?
So notes.
Take notes.
A lot of people who ran for president, they
ran for office, they ran for senate, governor,
one of the strengths all these guys had is
they had great memories of people that they
shook hands with.
Notes.
#10: Next, compliment.
I'm here to tell you today, if I'm a betting
man, I'm here to tell you, you have probably
not gotten a compliment today.
I'm telling you right now.
If I'm a betting man, I'm betting 70% of you
that are watching this, no one has complimented
you here today.
Now.
You may say, "Well, there's really nothing
to compliment me about."
Ah, that's not the real reason.
People just don't compliment enough.
Okay?
And those who are memorable are some of the
best at making other people feel good about
themselves.
That makes them memorable.
So other people want to be around them.
Compliment more.
#11: Next, how can I help?
Simple as that.
How can I help?
When I was a brand new entrepreneur and I
was coming up, the way I build relationships,
I was 21 years old, 20 years old, 22 years
old.
And I didn't know anybody.
I don't come from a family of a person that
ran a restaurant or a business or a liquor
store or a dealership, nothing.
My family doesn't own a business, so no one
in my lineage is a business that I can learn
any of that stuff.
So I said, the most important thing to me
is relationships.
So I said, "Okay, who are the most influential
people I know?
How can I help this person?"
Every time I met somebody, I had one outcome.
How can I serve you?
How can I help you?
It doesn't matter how.
Hey, my son's in prison.
Do you mind going and visiting him?
I haven't seen him for the longest time and
his heart's broken.
He feels alone.
He needs to talk to somebody."
No problem.
Go and get a security clearance and I'm going
to this prison.
How can I help you?
This person over here, they need a pen pal.
Do you mind writing letters to them.
All you need to do is once a quarter.
No problem.
How can I help you?
This person over here, their car is over here,
do you mind if you go out there?
No problem.
I know somebody.
Let me connect them.
How can I?
Everything becomes how can I help you?
Then all of a sudden, what happens is, there
was so much help going out, that the next
thing you know, thousands, thousands were
coming my way.
Because the focus was, how can I connect you,
how can I help you, who can I introduce you
to, how can I help?
So much help goes out, everyone remembers.
Initially before we started recording, I asked
Paul and I asked Edgar and I asked Z, I said,
Hey, who is the most memorable person you
met in the last 30 days.
Edgar said, "Magic Johnson."
Edgar was taking pictures.
And I said, "Why?"
And I said, Paul, why Magic Johnson?"
He said, "His story."
I said, "Okay.
His personality.
That's Magic's signature.
I said, "Edgar, how about you?"
And Edgar said his own reason.
I said, "What if he wasn't a basketball player?"
He said, I don't really know if I would remember
him.
And I said, "Yes you would, because he's 6'
9".
It's his unique style.
He's 6'9.
He's tall.
You're going to remember a guy that's 6'8,
6'9.
I said, "Z, who do you remember?"
Z said, Dennis Dotson.
I said, "Why Dennis?"
He said because Dennis was helping me out
with the camera.
I didn't know what I was doing.
Dennis helped me out with the camera.
He feels indebted to Dennis because Dennis
helped him.
That's memorable.
These are how simple this is.
It's not a complicated type of stuff to do
to be memorable that you need to go out there
and do.
It's very simple.
Anybody watching this, you can simply take
all this stuff, type it in an index card,
put it in your phone, put it on the shower
wall, when you're shaving in the morning,
the mirror.
Put it all over the place.
And you just keep telling yourself every day.
Eventually you'll notice yourself doing it
naturally and then people are going to say,
"I remember you.
I remember you.
Oh my gosh, you're so amazing.
How are you doing?
How's everything?"
Boom, boom, boom.
Then this becomes easy in business.
Paul, let's throw the pillow here.
Okay, my man.
You almost spilled protein.
No protein shakes around you, which is good
news.
All right, that's good, we're safe this time.
Okay, hey, if you haven't subscribed to this
channel yet, click on the button here, then
on the notifications, and you'll be one of
the first to receive the notification every
time these videos go up.
If you have any questions, thoughts, comments,
or another way to become memorable, post it
on the bottom.
And last but not least, if you watch this,
and you remember somebody that's very memorable,
send them this video and tell them when I
watch this, I said, "This is you, because
you're memorable."
Thanks for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.